[Music]  um and I you know getting kicked out of  that that practice that day I actually  spoke to duck  before practice I was like Doc I'm not  ready hey mentally I'm not ready please  just understand that you know I tried to  let him know prior  and he's like well I'm gonna put you in  anyway I'm like all right told me to get  in I was like I looked at him it was  like two it's like one minute into  practice like hey get in I'm like Fresno  no one's no one's doing that you're  doing this on purpose and that's how I  felt so I was like okay so you're it's  like it seems like everyone's just  trying to [ __ ] me know like I have I'm  getting fined for like not lifting  weights but  physically I'm like one of the strongest  guys on the [ __ ] team so I'm like now  I'm defining me for little things and  and it was just a build up of  obviously I didn't handle things the  right way but also the team didn't  either